why does this diet sound so
problematically familiar hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to aby's [Music]
Kitchen let me pop in here super quick folks cuz
I'm so excited to be working with element this is
a product that I was using years ago when I was
on my breastfeeding Sega and it really helped me
recover and I also use it a lot in the summer
when I'm playing tennis in the Heat and it's
always in my bag when I travel not to mention a
lot of my colleagues who work in Sports Nutrition
swear by element specifically because it's got a
science back electrolyte ratio of 1,000 mg sodium
200 Mig potassium and 60 Mig magnesium and it's
got no colors sugars or fillers I've also found
that having my electrolytes in the morning
has had a really big positive impact on my
sleep so even on days when I'm not sweating a lot
I will usually still have half a packet I love all
things spicy so the mango chili is always my fave
but they've got nine different flavors including
their new chocolate caramel which is so strangely
addictive right now element is offering my viewers
a free sample pack with any order so that's eight
single serving packets free with any element order
this is a great way to try eight other flavors or
share element with a salty friend so get yours at
drink element.com Abby sharp and this deal is only
available through my link so you have to go to d r
i n k l m nt.com slabby sharp today we're going
to be revisiting a super problematic diet that
I thought we had put to bed like 8 years ago but
here we are another beautiful fit blonde on social
media making a meal out of a crate of bananas yep
we're talking about the infamous raw till 4 high
carb lowfat low protein diet consisting largely of
fruit lettuce and potatoes if this sounds familiar
to you you are probably an OG aby's kitchen fan
so thank you guys so much for your loyalty we
love that but it's because I actually got my
start here on YouTube debunking this dangerous
raw vegan frore diet made famous by well another
beautiful fit blonde so there was a time when I
was receiving hundreds of messages and emails
and DMS from young girls following this diet
and suffering from horrendous outcomes hair loss
raging blood sugars acne severe IBS flares muscle
wasting amenorrhea and a lot more it is also not
lost on me that this is a very similar protocol to
the one followed by Russian raw vegan frugivore
Zan de art who passed away in the summer at age
39 allegedly related to malnutrition so I don't
know this feels a bit like a passing of the torch
to the next generation of raw vegan frugivores and
of course I have to worry about a similar fate but
we will be talking calories and restriction eating
today so that's just a little heads up here um and
if you're not already subscribed I would love
if you would and also check out my free Hunger
crushing combo ebook in the description below but
let's get into some of PA's videos and take a look
at what she recommends eating to prevent weight
gain to lose weight or to get rid of cellulite
news flash there is no diet specifically to do
that what I eat in a day so I can eat as much as
I want and never have to worry about weight gain
for breakfast I'm having 4 lbs of watermelon for
lunch I'm eating five Envy app app for a snack I'm
having a cluster of green grapes and for dinner
I've got a fresh crispy Roma salad along with
yellow curry potato soup now this is dangerous
and frankly just an incorrect assertion it doesn't
matter what kind of diet you want to follow keto
Weight Watchers calorie counting or raw till four
weight loss or weight gain comes down to calories
and if this works for Paige or for others it's
because you've been able to create a calorie
deficit not because it's super satiating in fact
despite this diet being made up of only fruit and
vegetables it is super low in hunger crushing
compounds now I'm not 100% sure what's in the
soup but I estimated around 2,000 calories 34 g of
protein 19 G of fat and 54 G of fiber and sure the
fiber is a lot higher than the national average
but it only makes up about 12% of total carbs not
great when we're not even hitting the bare minimum
protein targets so I would argue that most people
would not feel very full at all on a diet like
this and if you did it would be because of the
sheer volume or low caloric density of the foods
which she elaborates on here the average American
has about 4 pounds of food every day I eat over
double that I always start my morning off with
half of a watermelon which comes out to 4 and 1/2
lbs next up is six bananas at 1.3 lb for dinner I
eat this entire bowl of soup which has 2 lb of
potatoes in it I also have a large salad that
weighs about a half a pound the fact that eating 8
lbs of food is treated as like a flex is kind of a
red flag to me now I'm not diagnosing anyone with
anything I'm simply going to speak from my own
experience as a dietician and also someone who has
had a disorder but bragging about my massive meal
portions was exactly what I used to do to try to
hide my disorder you know I was like look at all
the food I eat there can't be anything wrong with
me look I eat see I eat a lot and honestly it kind
of worked like people saw me eat a lot so they
were thrown off on any suspicions that something
was wrong but eating massive amounts of ultra low
calorie foods in an attempt to stretch the Vagas
nerve and like trick my body into thinking that
I was truly nourished was a clear sign of my Ed
you know I just wanted so badly to feel full like
super full like physically a full full belly and
the only way to do that while not gaining weight
was to eat massive amounts of lettuce broth and
water-rich fruit obviously there is some Merit to
consuming more high volume Foods when on a weight
loss diet and that doesn't necessarily mean one
has an ed I mean we've got lots of research to
support that method but I think it's important
to remind ourselves that even if you can hack
your brain into thinking it's full by filling your
gut with a ton of water and bulk the likelihood of
feeling satisfied is super super slim like I ran
that race and it was very short-lived you cannot
Marathon it out on a hyper restrictive diet like
that without it completely messing with your head
and this sentiment from Paige on oils also feels
very very familiar the next thing I stopped eating
was oil I was all into the keto Vibe and the thing
is is like oil is not satiating and satisfying
oil does not fill you up all oil does is just give
you extra calories without actually giving you any
any bulk behind those calories without actually
filling you up and making you full and satisfied
I was very strong keto so I was like 80% of my
diet was fat my stomach was never getting filled
up it was just a bunch of high fat foods that I
was eating first of all I generally think it's a
red flake when I see folks yo-yo from one extreme
diet to another like case and point high fat keto
to lowfat raw vegan like why do we need to make
eating so complicated no but seriously here is my
take on oils and fats while trying to lose weight
fats contain more calories per gram than protein
or carbs but they're also very slow digesting
so they stabilize our insulin levels and keep
you feeling Fuller for longer now when wh loss
is the goal I do think we want to get the bulk
of our healthy fats from whole food sources
where they are bundled up with other hunger
crushing compounds so avocado for example is rich
in healthy fats and fiber nuts have healthy fats
protein and fiber salmon has healthy fats and
protein Etc now oils are just pure fat AKA they
are only one hunger crushing compound but that
doesn't mean they don't contribute to fullness or
satisfaction or that they cannot fit in a weight
loss diet on the contrary Reese suggest that added
oil does help to reduce appetite and hunger
hormones when added to our meals it also makes
food taste better which is super important for the
satisfaction piece like I would be so miserable
eating dry lettuce with no dressing you bet I
would be face planning into a family-sized bag of
chips and on top of the oil rant let's clear up
some science really easy for your body to convert
the fat that you eat into the fat that you wear so
it takes a lot less energy for the body to convert
dietary fat into fat storage on the body but it's
a lot harder and takes more energy to convert
carbohydrates into fat storage which makes sense
because fat is already fat so it's easy to convert
dietary fat into fat storage because it's already
fat that is not how weight gain Works carbs may
be our body's preferred fuel for immediate energy
but that doesn't mean that they can't be converted
to fat in fact if you really want to get down
to the nitty-gritty you could maybe argue that
foods that increase insulin or promote insulin
resistance May preferentially promote fat storage
and if that's what wak gain actually came down to
then carbs might actually be the bigger culprit
particularly low fiber high sugar carbs like
bananas grapes watermelon Etc but as I discussed
in my video on insulin right here the truth is
all of those details kind of come out in the
wash so ultimately it really doesn't matter what
the energy source is if you have more calories
AKA energy then what you need that substrate is
going to be stored as fat carbs too how much of
your diet should be carbohydrates what should be
protein and what should be fat what percentage
should all of this be so I like to stick to
80% of My overall calories coming from clean
carbohydrates 10% from fat and 10% from protein
and the beautiful thing is is that when you're
eating the right Foods you're going to naturally
fall into this macronutrient ratio without even
trying you don't have to count your Macros you
don't have to stress out and put everything into
my fitness pal no none of that that's why this
lifestyle is so free because as long as you're
eating the right Foods you're naturally going to
fall into that AG 101 macronutrient ratio without
even having to try probably not I mean assuming
that calories are appropriate North Americans
pretty consistently consume about 15% of their
calories from protein there's actually a really
interesting concept called the protein leverage
hypothesis that suggests that protein intake is
more strongly regulated in the body than the
intake of carbohydrates and fats and when we
reduce our protein intake below 15% we compensate
by increasing our calories until we reach that 50
15% so if you're not also carefully controlling
calories and you're just going Hog Wild on all
the fruit there is a pretty good chance you are
not going to end up in a calorie deficit now I
could have easily been off on my calculations
above seeing as I don't know what she puts in
her soup but what I calculated was even more
extreme than what she recommends here and what
she recommends is pretty bad especially for weight
loss I talked about optimal macros for weight loss
in my video right here but fat loss increases
is fourfold when we go from 10 to 15% of our
calories from protein to 20 to 30% but even if
fat loss is not the goal this is not even enough
for like Baseline bare minimum Health the lowest
of the low recommendations for protein is8 to 1
gam per kilogram of body weight and that is like
bottom of the barrel basic that is not if we are
trying to lose weight or build muscle so for 120
lb person that is just 43 to 54 g of protein per
day that is relased so little in my professional
opinion and yet this diet doesn't even provide
that poor protein intake can result in muscle
wasting reduced energy digestibility and fatty
liver and these effects can persist well beyond
quitting the diet ditto for low fat we know that
fat intakes below 20% can result in hormone
disregulation so basically low testosterone
in men and low estrogen in women which obviously
can affect fertil you know I keep thinking that
debunking content like this is like Captain
Obvious like no Sherlock it is not a good idea
to eat 4 pound of watermelon every single day but
then I see comments like this and I'm like I have
so much empathy for the vulnerable individuals who
are following this and well of course there will
always be folks on the fringes who will thrive
on a diet like this but it is a pretty slippery
slope for like everyone else so bottom line folks
fruit is amazing fruit is nutritious I love fruit
but a girl cannot thrive on fruit alone even if
you throw in some potatoes so if you were looking
for specific details on the optimal macro splits
for your specific goals definitely check out my
video right here and on that note that's all that
I have for you guys today if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up I would love to hear
your comments below keep it kind we do want to
be respectful here and I will see you next time
on Abby's kitchen bye come on Poppy oh she did
[Music] girl